oui j'ai effectivement été victime d'un
vol c'est extrêmement banal
malheureusement en France aujourd'hui on
est je pense des milliers de commerçants
à vivre ça au quotidien quelques jours
après j'ai porté plainte là on est déjà
moins nombreux à le faire aujourd'hui en
tant que commerçant un peu découragé un
peu voilà on se demande si ça va aboutir
ou pas et puis deux jours après j'ai
convoqué mon équipe en leur disant je
vais faire quelque chose que j'ai pas le
droit de faire j'ai diffusé les images
des voleurs sur les réseaux sociaux sans
foutait le visage voilà moi j'ai envie
de vous poser la question à ma place
vous auriez fait quoi Monsieur le
Ministre ah j'aurais pas diffusé alors
je vous dis alors d'abord je pense que
c'est
ultra pénible et rageant de se faire
voler quand on tient un commerce les
images oui là vous avez flouté les
visages ah mais je les ai vu ces images
sur Twitter j'ai vu effectivement je
pense qu'on enrage quand on est
commerçant et qu'on se fait voler son
outil de travail comme ça je pense qu'on
aura h donc je pense que je serai pas en
colère mais vous savez il y a un concept
avec lequel je suis très attaché c'est
qu'on ne se fait pas justice soi-même je
suis un profond républicain je fais
confiance dans le système judiciaire
quand ça va pas faut le transformer il
faut le renforcer pour en discuter je
pourrais vous dire en quelques mots ce
qu'on va faire en l'occurrence mais je
vous dis juste je veux pas d'une société
je veux pas une société dans laquelle on
finit par se faire justice soi-même même
si ça démange même si on en rage encore
une fois parce que
alors vous allez me dire vous avez des
preuves à l'évidence que ce sont eux
mais je pourrais vous citer des exemples
de personnes qui ont été victimes des
ragudiciaires ou de lynchage parce que
les gens considéraient qu'ils étaient
forcément coupables et donc pour ça
qu'on a un système de justice dans un
état de droit qui doit fonctionner
néanmoins il faut un vous avez raison
que les plaintes soient déposer qu'elles
soient prises les enquêtes aillent plus
vite il faut qu'on ait une justice qui
soit capable de juger plus vite donc je
sais pas si vous avez regardé ce qu'on a
ce qu'on a voté ces dernières années et
ce que les engagements qui ont été pris
par Eric Dupond-Moretti qui est le garde
des sceaux je sais pas si vous avez vu
un petit peu l'augmentation des
effectifs la numérisation mais sachez
plutôt que de vous abonner de chiffres
donner ici à la fin du quinquennat la
justice pour tous les faits civils
qui relève du civil aura été multiplié
par deux la vitesse d'accord donc on
mettra deux fois moins de temps à juger
ça c'est un point qui est essentiel
parce que encore plus enrageant de se
faire voler encore plus en rageant
d'avoir parfois des difficultés pour
porter plainte c'est quand derrière ça
prend des plombes et vous savez même
plus quand vous parle donc là il faut
que ça aille beaucoup plus vite on va
aussi utiliser le numérique donc on va
pouvoir davantage porter plainte en
ligne être en contact avec la justice en
ligne mieux prendre soin des victimes on
peut réagir ensemble bien sûr j'ai pas
fait justice moi-même j'ai voulu aider
la police vous avez j'ai aidé la police
monstrueux mais avec une intention
derrière oui je l'ai fait parce que
j'avais envie que ces gens-là on les
arrête et aujourd'hui les forces de
police elles n'ont plus les moyens elles
sont débordées mais vous voulez
que des gens dans la rue arrête la
personne parce que si j'étais pas passé
dans cette émission quelques jours après
je pense que on en serait au point mort
comme des milliers et des milliers de
Français de commerçants français qui ont
porté plainte
puis qui attendent qu'un jour il se
passe quelque chose parce que c'est
complexe c'est complexe de les
interpeller c'est complexe de les de les
condamner ensuite parce que les
condamnés à quoi d'ailleurs grâce à la
béatisation de ça effectivement on va
les retrouver mais si je passe pas dans
cette émission si je fais pas ce petit
buzz vous l'appelez comme ça auprès des
radios et des télés qui m'ont reçu dans
cette journée un peu surprenante pour
moi on les retrouve pas parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez des Français
qui tous les jours vont porter plainte
monsieur verre tous les jours moi je
veux dire quelque chose vous voyez voilà
ce que j'ai mis sur la devanture de mon
magasin
j'ai mis magasin établissement sous
vidéo surveillance en cas de vol
attendez
nous diffusons les images sur les
réseaux sociaux
et moi j'incite les commerçants qui le
veulent n'ont pas à diffuser sur les
réseaux sociaux mais à commencer à faire
changer la peur de côté aujourd'hui
c'est les commerçants qu'on peut c'est
les vendeuses dans les magasins qui ont
peur monsieur va c'est les vendeurs qui
sont régulièrement embêtés et puis
derrière il y a tellement d'affaires de
violences conjugales de bagarres
d'agressions et vous le savez
aujourd'hui le vol de des trois
vêtements chez moi ou de ce qui se passe
tous les jours dans tous les magasins ça
passe après et ça aujourd'hui c'est plus
possible les commerçants en ont marre et
j'ai une proposition à vous faire
vous faites des guichet unique je vous
ai entendu tout à l'heure je vous ai
écouté et je pense que vous êtes un
gouvernement extrêmement ouvert je le
souhaite en tous les cas parce que nous
on est à l'écoute de ce que vous allez
nous proposer
j'ai pris mon agenda ce que j'espère
qu'on aura l'occasion de prendre
rendez-vous pour travailler sur le sujet
la mission elle est formidable elle
permet de faire savoir mais derrière il
faut agir pourquoi est-ce que demain on
envisage pas que les commerçants
français qui viennent tous les jours au
commissariat de Versailles ou ailleurs
pour porter plainte pourquoi est-ce
qu'il n'y aurait pas un accueil
spécifique pour ces commerçants qui vont
attendre deux ou trois heures avant que
leur plainte soit enregistrées donc ils
n'y vont plus est-ce que c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on peut réfléchir
envisageant ensemble on a fait on a fait
un guichet prioritaire dans les comics
Gérald Darmanin qui l'a porté dans les
hôtels de police et les gendarmerie pour
les femmes victimes de violence parce
que là il y a une notion d'urgence de
protection et de préservation immédiate
donc là il y a un système de coupe fil
pour leur permettre de le faire
moi je vais vous dire quelque chose je
crois
je crois pas du tout à l'exclusion par
le numérique et je pense qu'il faut
laisser évidemment des points d'accueil
physique parce qu'il y a des gens qui
n'utilisent pas forcément le numérique
je par contre je crois sincèrement que
la France doit être capable demain comme
d'autres pays et c'est d'ailleurs notre
volonté de pouvoir aussi avoir un
système de plein temps en ligne et
tulipes de votre dossier en ligne
directement donc c'est clair je vous dis
il y a une loi qui a été portée par Eric
Dupond-Moretti on va rajouter 8000
officiers de justice magistrats
greffiers on va multiplier par deux la
vitesse de la justice on va favoriser
les traitements des dossiers etc tenir
davantage compte d'ailleurs de la
situation dans laquelle se trouve les
victimes ce qui était aussi une priorité
pour nous vous avez aussi une
augmentation des forces de police
effective etc vous êtes Damien c'est ça
donc peut-être qu'à mieux avant il y
avait une voiture de bac qui tournait la
nuit maintenant il doit y en avoir trois
ou quatre ce qui a quand même un impact
très important je vous dis les chiffres
comme ça mais vous voyez l'ordre de
grandeur chez moi à Grenoble c'est le
cas et ça permet vraiment de d'améliorer
la sécurité mais dans votre insécurité
du quotidien tel que vous la décrivez je
la croiserai et pour les gens qui
travaillent avec vous dans les commerces
et qui voient des voleurs et qui sont au
contact de gens qui sont parfois
virulents la
vidéo est un système de protection qui
permet de retrouver les les auteurs par
contre je vous dis juste là où je ne
vous suis pas le seul point sur lequel
je vous suis pas dans cette discussion
mais j'ai compris qu'il y avait des
faits à tirer l'attention d'eux mais si
tout le monde se met à publier sur les
réseaux sociaux les photos visage
découvertes de gens dont ils estiment
qu'il auront causé du tort en fait la
société elle va pas y survivre je vous
le dis très clairement parce que il va
se passer quoi c'est des lynchage des
meute on organise des voilà c'est parce
qu'on veut donc je vous dis par rapport
à ça que ce soit une alerte pour dire
aux gens faites attention sinon vous
risquez d'être embêté épaque par la
police mais ne diffusons pas ne
commençons pas à rentrer dans cette
diffusion dans cette société de
diffusion des visages des gens
je sais pas c'est potentiellement je
suis pas sûr qu'il risque grand chose en
pratique mais ça reste un délit ça reste
un délit parce que parce que il faut
vraiment comprendre pourquoi j'ai déjà
entendu Cyril dans cette émission des
propos sur le fait de des intentions ou
de la spontanéité avec laquelle on
pourrait se faire j'utilise soi-même je
vous le dis on peut on peut râler on
peut trouver que ça va pas assez vite
qu'à passer le moyen on l'entend et on
le pense puisqu'on nous-mêmes on fait en
sorte que ça aille plus vite et on
rajoute des moyens mais jamais on ne
doit tomber dans une société où on se
fait justice soi-même chez le ministre
il y a une augmentation janvier 2022 de
quasiment 20 % de vol en plus dans les
magasins alors vous savez qu'il y a une
réduction des cambriolages de 25% là sur
l'année non mais c'est les chiffres mais
ouais
c'est c'est quand même le prénom des
chiffres vous voulez considérer comme
factuel quand je présente les chiffres
de la police nationale on les décris
bilise ça veut dire qu'on peut pas c'est
à dire qu'on fait pas confiance en sa
police mais je fais confiance à ma
police et les chiffres de la police de
gendarmes c'est aujourd'hui vous avez
25% de baisse des cambriolages vous avez
20%, mais il y a encore beaucoup trop
d'actes de délinquance personne ne dit
le contraire vous voyez ce que je veux
dire moi je vous dis ce qui se passe à
Amiens se passe à Dunkerque à Grenoble
avant Bruschi partout partout en France
aujourd'hui les commerçants j'attire
juste votre attention sur ce fait là les
commerçants du tout du tout
ils en ont ils en ont marre parce que
effectivement aujourd'hui ils sont face
à un mur et aujourd'hui vous avez des
magasins où les gens entrent et
repartent avec des vêtements et plus
personne ne fait rien parce qu'on a plus
les moyens parce que les filles elles
vont pas risquer leur vie pour attraper
un vêtement la justice derrière vous
dites ils vont ils vont ils risquent
rien donc ils vont recommencer pour
modifier
c'est un ah non c'est un délit c'est
pénal si on le voulait on pourrait
modifier les choses l'installation d'un
guichet qui permettrait de recevoir les
commerçants je vous regarde dans les
yeux quand je vous dis ça vous aideriez
les commerçants non mais c'est souvent
donc forcément derrière voilà vous savez
quoi de toute façon je vous ai dit je
vous ai dit que j'arrivais ici l'esprit
ouvert donc je dis pas qu'on allait
solution pour tout donc moi je suis
d'accord vous proposer qu'on se voit
donc on va vous donner une carte vous
n'êtes pas le premier ce soir qui fait
donner une carte et c'est très bien
comme ça et je veux bien qu'on en
discute et qu'on regarde ensemble et je
veux bien qu'on fasse expertiser votre
proposition enfin je veux dire j'ai
commencé j'ai commencé cette émission
Cyril en disant que chaque Français est
utile et que les idées qui sont les
vôtres et que les tracas ou que les CE
la détresse dans laquelle vous pouvez
évoluer au quotidien je dis pas que nous
états gouvernement on a des solutions
pour tout je dis juste qu'on est bardé
de bonnes intentions et qu'on a envie de
bien faire d'accord il y a des choses
qu'on peut faire des choses qu'on ne
peut pas faire ou parce que c'est pas
légal ou parce qu'on a pas les moyens de
le faire ou parce qu'on peut pas le
faire tout de suite ça n'empêche pas de
se poser la question de savoir si on
peut le suivre donc moi je suis ouvert
moi je pars
il sera plutôt que minuit
il serait pas sur un fauteuil qui tourne
merci à très bientôt